SUDHIR HASBE: Welcome, everyone,
to What's New in BigQuery?
session.
I'm Sudhir Hasbe.
I'm the director of
product for smart analytics
platform at Google Cloud.
TINO TERESHKO: And
I'm Tino Tereshko.
I'm a product manager
on Google BigQuery.
SUDHIR HASBE: So at Google Cloud
in the smart analytics team,
our vision is to give
you or provide you
with an enterprise
class data platform
with proven dependability.
At Google, we believe in
building these large scale
services that can meet all
your security and trust needs.
So we basically have
been focused on that.
In addition to that, we are also
about being open and flexible,
providing you with choice.
And finally, and
most important, we
want to embed intelligence
across the whole platform.
So that's our primary vision
in the smart analytics team.
Let's talk about BigQuery first.
Google BigQuery--
it's now 10 years old.
In June, we celebrated the
10th anniversary of BigQuery.
BigQuery has customers
from a few terabytes
to hundreds of petabytes.
It's a completely
serverless technology.
What do I mean by that?
Well, it means you don't have to
worry about any infrastructure
pieces.
Just bring your data
and start analyzing.
Start writing queries on it.
There is no monitoring.
There is no administration.
There is no machines.
There is no nodes.
There are no servers that
you need to worry about.
So most of that is
managed by Google.
We take care of
all that for you.
The second thing-- we are
highly differentiated.
We provide you capability
to ingest tens of millions
of events in real
time into BigQuery.
And a lot of
organizations like King,
which is a gaming company--
they have in-game
events that happen,
and they want to stream
that in real time
so they can analyze what users
are doing on their platform.
So it's possible-- and many
[INAUDIBLE] large scale
events--
it does not impact your query
performance on top of that data
because we completely
distribute or decouple
our compute and storage layers.
In addition to that, we
have embedded machine
learning capability,
where you can
write SQL commands to create
machine learning models
and get advanced predictions.
And finally, we don't want
insights to be limited
to few in the organization.
We want insights for everyone.
We have made a lot of
investment in the space,
but BigQuery is being used by
organizations like AirAsia,
where they were able to
reduce their operational costs
in an airline by
5% to 10% by making
those insights available
to everybody in front line
so that they can make
better decisions.
So those are the key
capabilities that we provide.
One thing that BigQuery
is great at is scale.
We are really powering some of
the largest of the workloads
in analytics space.
Our largest customer has
more than 350 petabytes
of data in the data warehouse.
One of the largest
queries that was run
was roughly 100
trillion rows that
were queried in a single query.
And now we have seen up to
10,000 concurrent users being
used by one of our customers.
So concurrency at
a very high scale
is also supported in a big way.
Let's talk about HSBC.
It's a systemic bank.
It's highly regulated.
HSBC uses BigQuery to
a lot of large scale
analytics for a lot of
regulatory reporting and all.
One of the key
things that we were
able to do by
working with HSBC is
provide a lot of
security capabilities
in BigQuery, like CMEK.
That's customer manager
encryption keys.
Virtual private connect.
So all of these VPC SC--
all these capabilities
we built with HSBC.
They are proven.
They're used by some of the
largest banks in the world.
In HSBC's case, they bring
data from 40 plus countries--
all transaction data--
they put it into their
data lake/data warehouse.
With BigQuery they
analyze all of this data,
and at the end of
the day, they have
to report to regulators about
the viability of the business
based on all this data.
And all of this is running
in few minutes, which
used to take like, I think, 30
hours on PREM systems and stuff
like that.
And you have to do this
every day, so at 30 hours,
you cannot go out
and report every day.
So on BigQuery, we can
do it in a few minutes,
and it's allowing
them to scale--
to scale their business.
TINO TERESHKO: So BigQuery is
much more than a data warehouse
because we have so much
advanced capabilities,
but one strength of
BigQuery is the fact
that it is a part of
a tightly integrated
broad smart analytics platform
that includes services
like Dataproc, Data
Fusion, and even Looker.
And actually, the vast
majority of BigQuery customers
are using a number
of these services
together with BigQuery.
And Sky UK is one of them.
Of course, Sky is a broadcaster.
And they provide
these enhanced set
top boxes that communicate data
directly to Pub/Sub, Dataflow,
and BigQuery for
real time analysis.
What that enables Sky to
do is to really understand
the customer deeply.
They're able to visualize
what customers are doing,
what they're watching,
their preferences.
They're able to tailor
customized content
and advertisements,
so on and so forth.
And they even can do research on
customers by doing A/B testing.
SUDHIR HASBE: And if you look
at the growth of BigQuery,
we have seen tremendous
growth in last year or so.
We have customers across
every industry vertical,
across every region
in the world.
We have large customers
like Home Depot
to UPS in the United States.
We have HSBC.
We have Sky.
We have King.
We have various
different customers--
Metro, Ocado, and EMEA.
We also have customers
in our JAPAC region,
like Fast Retailing Group, ANZ
Bank, and Gojek and Air Asia,
and all.
So we have seen adoption
across the globe
by different customers
with different kinds
of use cases and [INAUDIBLE].
So for today's roadmap
session, what we did was
we have taken some of the key
highlights in the roadmap,
and we want to
share them with you.
And we are going to do this
across the three value pillars
that we have-- being
open and flexible,
intelligent, and with
proven dependability.
TINO TERESHKO: Let's start
with proven dependability.
HSBC and Sky, of course,
multinational corporations
that put their
trust into BigQuery
to drive their business forward.
So we really need to take care
of our customers in this area.
And so what we think about it
is we enhance dependability
in four areas--
availability and uptime,
administration and control,
performance, and
just query execution,
and, finally, trust,
security, and governance.
Today, we're announcing the
fact that we are enhancing
our SLA by an additional nine.
So now there's four nines
availability that we guarantee.
We're doing this free of
charge to all of our customers.
There's no special rates
that you have to pay.
The reason we're able
to do this is because we
have serverless architecture.
It's a very advanced
radically unique architecture
that does guarantee
against downtime
in specific circumstances.
So these four nines
of availability
is really only about four
minutes of downtime per month,
or less than an hour per day.
And you know that it is actually
industry leading when it
comes to cloud data warehouses.
All other warehouses only offer
three nines of availability.
And, of course, we
care about performance,
and our customers care
about performance.
So we started running this
query in the last few years
to demonstrate the
power of BigQuery.
This is a query that is
a simple point look up,
but it is a query on an
entire petabyte worth of data.
So in 2016, when we
first ran this query,
it executed in
about six minutes,
and it scanned the
whole petabyte.
In 2018, a couple of years
later, we executed this query
in just two minutes,
and it actually
scanned about 400 megabytes.
Today, if you run this
query in BigQuery,
you will notice that it takes
about four seconds to run.
And the best part of
all is that you didn't
need to do anything special.
You didn't need to
pay anything extra
to start getting this
better performance.
We just upgraded
your service for you
seamlessly without any
downtime, and you just
got better performance.
In fact, just in 2020 alone,
from the beginning of the year,
we've made major improvements
to all the typical industry
standard benchmarks.
This is a TPC-DS benchmark,
and we're looking
at the geo mean of performance.
So both for 1T,
10T, and 30T scales,
we improve performance
anywhere from 20% to 30%.
And again, you just
get this performance
as part of using BigQuery.
You don't have to do
anything, and it just happens.
So we have a number of
customers in all kinds of areas.
And, of course, sports
leagues and sports teams
are taken advantage
of BigQuery--
major league baseball
being the newest one.
There's a breakdown, DA204,
that talks about the journey
that MLB took to kind of
re-platform onto BigQuery.
Well, the first
thing they noticed
when they started using
BigQuery is the fact
that they're able to give this
information, to give analytics
to all the key stakeholders
within Major League
Baseball and the teams that
are part of the league.
And they're able to
do this in real time.
They don't have these
bottlenecks anymore.
At the same time,
they're getting
performance that's significantly
better than the previous--
the previous platform.
And finally, it's very, very
easy for them to manage this.
Because BigQuery is
serverless, there's
really not a lot of things
for them to worry about,
and they really like that.
So we talked about how
BigQuery is serverless it
doesn't require administration.
That said, the more
customers we have that
are multinational,
that are complicated--
they have lots of
business units--
the more they're asking
for better control,
better predictability,
better visibility.
So we've made the
significant investments here.
Just in 2020 alone,
we've launched a number
of improvements to BigQuery.
The first one
being Reservations.
Reservations is an enterprise
grade workload management
platform that allows you to
achieve predictable pricing
and to make sure that all
your work loads are executing
under the proper SLAs.
And it's super efficient because
it's using idle capacity.
The next enhancement
is flex slots.
Flex slots allow you to
purchase capacity just
for a few seconds at a time,
and you can cancel them anytime.
You essentially get
instant capacity
to meet your workload demands.
And for the classic database
administrators out there,
we've made a number of
enhancements, as well.
One is information schema.
These are just tables
that contain metadata
relevant to your service.
We've made enhancements
of data types,
and we've made improvements
to SQL [INAUDIBLE] as well.
I'm really delighted
about this feature.
It's coming in the
next few months--
BigQuery slot autoscaling.
So this kind of combines
the best of both worlds.
You're getting the
price predictability
of slots based pricing, and you
get the low management overhead
that's associated with
our on demand model.
BigQuery slots
autoscaling allows
you to configure your scaling
limits and your spend limits,
and BigQuery takes
care of the rest.
We will certainly scale up and
down your workloads, depending
on what you throw at BigQuery.
So some of the things that
are really relevant about this
is the fact that this supports
the auto pause and the auto
start mode.
So we can go from
zero to full scale
and back to zero
if you like that.
Because we are not
powered by VMs,
you get a lot of
additional advancements.
So for example, we don't
have this pre-warm period
when you're not getting
optimal performance.
The second you
get your capacity,
performance is at 100%.
Also, if you have queries
in flight, queries
that are being executed,
you can add capacity,
and those queries
would immediately
start taking advantage of that.
So you can accelerate
queries in flight
using BigQuery slots autoscale.
Because we don't have VMs,
we're not powered by--
we're not powered by local disk.
So we don't have those
local disk bottlenecks.
If you start running
out of local disk,
you start getting performance
clips that are unpredictable.
They're hard to monitor
for and hard to document.
We don't have such problems.
We always have hot data for you.
And finally, we kind of
already talked about this
in the SLA slides, but we
can provide a high level
of reliability because we're
immune to individual node
downtime.
In fact, a huge portion of
a data center can come down,
and you're not even
going to notice that.
The next feature we're
launching in administration
in the next few months
is admin panel UI.
Now, we have stack driver
from [INAUDIBLE] which
is incredibly powerful,
but our customers
want us to also have BigQuery
native monitoring capability.
So Admin Panel will provide
you with the ability
to monitor your queries,
your slots, your resources,
your spent, your workloads, and
your users right in BigQuery
from BigQuery.
This will have a real
time component to it,
so you can see what's
happening right this second.
And you can go back in time
several weeks and months.
So how are you going
to use Admin Panel?
Well, you're going to
be able to figure out
how your organization is
using BigQuery in general.
Who are your top users?
What are the types of
queries they're running?
And you're also going to be able
to perform real time root cause
analysis whenever
things go wrong.
Maybe there is a for
loop that went awry.
So you want to catch that, and
you figure out what's going on,
and move on.
Customers always ask us,
you have all these pricing
capabilities, but how do I
choose which model to use?
Which one is the
right one for me?
And how much capacity
should I purchase?
So we're launching
BigQuery slot Recommender.
With BigQuery slot
Recommender we're
going to run this
intelligence, and we're
going to send you
insights automatically
that will actually
recommend whether you should
be on the on demand
model, or whether you
should be on the slots model.
And of course, we're
going to do this
without sacrificing performance.
So we're going to
tell you that there's
a recommendation out there.
It's going to recommend you
to save money without actually
sacrificing performance.
So we talked about availability.
We talked about administration.
We talked about performance,
but probably the most important
aspect of BigQuery
is its security.
Our customers trust us with
their data and their workloads,
and we can't fail them.
So we have a kind of a
three-pronged strategy here.
The first one is BigQuery
is a part of Google,
and Google employs thousands
of the best security
engineers in the world.
They're working on security,
on custom hardware, networking,
penetration, so on and so forth.
And BigQuery gets to benefit
from all of this innovation.
That's the beauty of BigQuery.
That's the first pillar.
So you just get a
high level of security
automatically with BigQuery.
The second pillar is
the fact that we're
giving you a number of
controls, and configurations,
and services that enable you
to customize how much security
you want in your environment--
things like Sudhir
mentioned customer
managed encryption keys,
virtual private networking.
But the key to this
component is Data Catalog.
Data Catalog is a metadata
management and discovery
service that we
launched recently.
So imagine your data
coming into Google Cloud.
Data Catalog can
automatically index that data.
Then the data passes
through data loss prevention
API that removes
and tokenizes PII
information and private
and secure information.
And then you can apply tags
and policies to this data,
and grant access to the
right levels of data
to the right users inside
of your organization.
So it's a super flexible,
super powerful platform
for data management that
allows you to really control
how your data is exposed
internally and externally.
And the third pillar that's
critical to our success
here is the fact
that we're working
with all the relevant agencies
to achieve these audits
and certifications.
So if you're storing medical
data inside of BigQuery,
you know you can
trust us because we
have HIPAA certification.
If you're storing financial
data inside of BigQuery,
you know you can
trust us because we
have TCI certification.
If you're doing business
in Germany or Singapore,
we have proper
credentials, as well.
And with FedRAMP we can do
business with government.
SUDHIR HASBE: With
that, now we talked
about proven dependability.
Let's switch gears, talk
about the intelligence.
One of our key capabilities
in Google Cloud
is, of course, our capabilities
around machine learning and AI.
And we will talk
more about how we
are enhancing that embedded
machine learning capabilities
that we are providing
with BigQuery,
but also talk about some real
time analytics improvements
that we have done.
But before that, let's talk
about democratizing insights.
One of our key value
pillars in Google Cloud
is we want insights
for everyone.
We want to make sure
every individual person
in an organization can
get access to the insights
that they want.
So in this realm, the first
thing that we are doing
is our refresh to BigQuery UI.
A lot of our customers
have been asking
for capabilities in BigQuery
UI, like multi type editing.
We are adding that.
So it's now available
for everyone to use.
It's a really great
experience where
you can write multiple
different queries, compare them.
But more importantly, you not
only write SQL for BigQuery.
You can also write data flow SQL
and create streaming pipelines
with Pub/Sub and Dataflow in
combination with BigQuery.
So it does allow you that
that integrated experience.
It's a faster ID, and one
of the other features I like
is this auto complete for me.
So it can recommend
or suggest what
are the table or fields
that I should be using,
and stuff like that.
So a lot of innovation and
investment going in that space.
And the second thing--
I'm super excited
about this feature,
which is Connected Sheets.
Connected Sheets is literally
think about Google Sheet
in front of BigQuery.
You can have petabyte scale
data sets in BigQuery.
You can use Sheets to
go ahead and create
pivot tables, charts, our
functions, and our custom
calculations on
top of the sheet.
And then all of that actually
runs on top of BigQuery.
So it's best of both
worlds-- the great experience
with great analytical engine.
I personally use this every day.
I have 29 plus
billion row table.
I analyze data from that every
day about our product usage--
what's working, what's
not working, and on.
So really this
makes data at scale
accessible to all analysts
who can use spreadsheets
within your organization.
So it's really powerful tooling.
But with that, we
don't want to stop
at analysts and just a few
folks in the organization.
We want to extend
insights to everyone
else in the organization.
With that, we are announcing
availability of Data QnA.
Our Data QnA is natural
language interface for BigQuery.
You literally go ahead and
ask a question, get an answer.
It's as simple as that.
There is no set up
required on top of BigQuery
for leveraging it.
You just enable an API, pick the
people that you want to go to
and ask questions on.
And we just make
it possible for you
so you can just
start leveraging it.
We also believe that
no one interface
is the right interface
for technology like this.
I think organizations want
to build custom workflows
and custom experiences on
top of such a technology.
So we do have the whole
API available for Data QnA,
but there are--
organizations can literally
build their own experiences.
But from Google's side,
we will be integrating it
into Google Sheets.
With Connected Sheets
plus Direct QnA,
now we have a very
powerful experience.
We will be providing
chat board experience.
We will be working
with dialog flow
and various other experiences
that we can provide directly,
including BigQuery UI will
have a version of this.
All of this is actually
built on an internal Google
technology called Analyzer.
There's a great paper that
you can read more about it on.
But fundamentally, this
is the same technology
that powers Google Assistant
and various other services
and products that
we internally use.
Analyzer gives us
the ability to go out
and to question parsing,
intent identification, entity
matching.
All of that comes because
of Google's investment
in the space of
natural language,
conversational
understanding, and all.
And we're just
leveraging parts of that.
We are, on BigQuery's
side, making sure
that that works really well
with your custom data sets,
and we can make it easy
to go ahead and get
started without doing
that much of preparation
and set up on your data sets.
Let me switch gears, talk about
embedded machine learning.
One of the key values that
we have in BigQuery team
is we want to bring computation
to data, not the other way
around.
We don't like moving
data, copying data.
That's not the best way of
running large scale analytics.
And so in the same realm,
80% of prime data scientists
today are spending
in data preparation
according to some studies.
We want to avoid that.
With BigQuery,
what you can do is
you can just use
two lines of SQL
to create machine
learning models.
You literally say create
model, model name, of type,
x regression, matrix
factorization,
whatever you want.
And then give the
input data set,
and we will do everything
for you on that.
We do internal
hyperparameter tuning.
We can even take care of the
whole system on the back end.
When we launched a
couple of years back,
we only had regression,
and logistical, and linear
regression models.
From there, we have
come far, far ahead.
We now support
k-means clustering,
matrix factorization.
I've seen lot of organizations
use this in combination.
They do customer segmentation
using k-means clustering.
They do matrix factorization
to find products
that we should recommend
to those segments,
and they've basically done
email campaigns and ad campaigns
on them.
So very common pattern.
Now you can use
the use this for--
in addition, we've also launched
time series forecasting.
This is great for inventory
optimizations and stuff
like that.
So we were seeing a lot
of interest in this model,
but in addition to
that, we have enabled
BigQuery ML to be
the SQL interface
for a lot of our
capabilities in Cloud AI.
So [INAUDIBLE] classifiers, XG
posts, and auto ML tables all
are using Cloud AI platform
services behind the scenes,
and you still get the
same consistent experience
that you have.
But most importantly,
a lot of our customers
said to us, hey,
all these models,
creating them easily and running
batch workloads is great,
but I would love to use
these models in real time
predictions.
How do we enable that?
And so we enable you to go
ahead and export these models
directly into TensorFlow
model, and so you
can export it as
TensorFlow model,
and then host it in any of
the serving platform that
supports TensorFlow, which would
be a [INAUDIBLE],, Kubeflow.
There are various platforms
that are available that you
can run this with.
With that, we recovered
the democratizing insights,
especially with Data QnA
and Connected Sheets,
embedded machine learning.
The third area of
innovation that we
have spent significant amount of
time is in real time analytics.
As I earlier mentioned,
we have customers
that are supporting in
like tens of millions
of events per
second in BigQuery.
And just this year, we re-wrote
our whole storage engine
from batch first mode
to a streaming mode.
So it's a streaming
first storage system now,
and we can scale to
any of your needs.
Tens of millions of events per
second is without any problem.
The more important is
none of your queries
will get any-- have any
impact on performance
because of that ingestion rate.
So we can do tens of
millions of events
and give you the same query
performance in the real time,
and that's coming.
The second thing is
materialized views.
We know, when you have a lot
of these data changes happening
batch or in stream, you want
to materialize your data set
and views so that
you can easily power
the dashboards and
reports that you may have.
All of this is
automated in BigQuery.
Once you create a materialized
view, as the underlying data
changes, we persisted in the
materialized view for you.
What that means is you
don't have to worry
about scheduling these.
You will not have to worry about
when was the last update made
to the base table--
nothing like that.
We will always
keep it consistent.
And most important
is query re-routing.
What that means is, if you
fire a query into BigQuery,
and you created a
materialized view later,
and you have this
historical query,
we will automatically
take that query.
Our query passing
engine will realize
that you have a new
materialized view, which
can make the query run faster,
and we will automatically
leverage that.
So that's there.
It's available in beta
form for you to use now.
VI engine is another
third investment in always
fast, always fresh
[INAUDIBLE] for us.
A BI Engine-- we launched
the BI Engine last year
working within Data Studio
so that we had an integrated
experience.
We wanted to test
the technology,
make sure it can scale to
global needs, and all of that.
So I think that is there.
It provides you a sub-second
latency query capability.
It automatically
tunes your queries
as they come in and all.
But more importantly,
in this year,
we are going to extend that
capability of BI Engine, which
is out in memory caching engine,
to all the queries in BigQuery.
So when the query comes
in, it will be able
to leverage BigQuery, even from
a standard BigQuery interface.
In addition to that, all
your JDBC ODBC drivers
will support it.
And also, all of
our BI partners,
like Tableau, Looker,
Sisense, Domo, Power BI--
all of them will be able
to leverage the BI Engine
capability that we have.
We just pick what
your size of cache is,
and everything will
automatically work.
And then also one of the
other things we will support
is star schemas so
that all your BI work
will start-- taken care of.
Extending that, if you really
think from a stack perspective,
you, as customers today,
now have a choice.
You can decide whether
you want low latency,
or you're OK with
relatively higher latency.
And you can decide
how much you want
to use on the very hard
data with caching the--
with BI Engine, or you just
want to create materialized
view, which we will
keep fresh all the time.
Or you want to just
use partition tables
or just go to the
storage layer directly.
So all of this is a
choice that you have,
but you write the query.
We will automatically
first try BI Engine.
Not there.
Go to materialize view.
Go to partitioning
and clustering.
If not, go to the cold storage,
however the data is stored.
So that's the key thing that
we have been working on.
You will always get the best
performance at the best price.
So you can pick and choose
how-- what you care about.
With that, we
covered intelligence
and proven dependability.
Let's switch gears and talk
about open and flexible.
This is another
big theme for us.
We'll cover BigQuery
everywhere, flexible pricing,
as well as data platform
interoperability in this.
Let's talk about BigQuery--
BigQuery everywhere.
We are introducing
BigQuery Omni.
What is BigQuery Omni?
As I earlier said,
we have this theory--
vision in-- in BigQuery where we
like to bring compute to data.
A lot of our customers
have data not in GCP.
A lot of them have
data in AWS S3.
And maybe other
customers have in Azure.
So with BigQuery Omni
available for AWS,
we will allow you to write
queries, and execute,
and do analysis on top of
the data that's stored in S3.
What does this mean?
We will literally run
our compute engine--
our computation engine
or BigQuery in AWS
close up through your data.
And what that means
is you don't have
to worry about paying for this
egress charges or anything.
So you may have
tens of to hundreds
of terabytes of data in S3.
You can stop writing queries
with the same interface
in BigQuery or in the same
SQL dialect that we support,
as well as--
and run it on AWS.
So you'll be able to
do computation in that,
and then get access
to the results.
There are two or
three different kinds
of use cases that are becoming
really prevalent in this.
And a lot of our customers
do have split mode.
A lot our customers use BigQuery
and GCP, as well as they
have data in S3 and AWS.
This is going to allow you
to have a single interface
to analyze data across clouds.
And as I said, we
will be bringing out
the BigQuery Omni for
Azure in coming quarters,
so that will extend it
to that platform, too.
So that's one.
The second use case that is
becoming pretty prevalent
is I've been talking to
large customers who have tens
to hundreds of petabytes in S3.
They don't use GCP 3,
but they are intrigued
with our capabilities like the
BigQuery ML embedded machine
learning capability,
and they want to use it.
And so in this
case, what we can do
is we can enable those
organizations to do data
preparation,
summarizing the data,
identifying the key data
sets that are there,
and then just move the data
that you want to run machine
learning on to GCP in BigQuery,
and then let those machine
learning models do
advanced analytics with it.
So those are the different
kinds of use cases
we are seeing in the early
adoption that we have seen.
We are learning as we go,
and we would love for you
to request access, get
access to this technology.
And would love to co-innovate
with you in the space.
With that, let's
talk about pricing.
TINO TERESHKO: So we
talked about how BigQuery
has some of the largest
use cases in the world,
but what's interesting
is BigQuery probably
also has some of the smallest
use cases in the world.
And it's really because
we build our system
to be scale invariate, and we
build the right pricing options
to support that kind of
gradient of scenarios.
So no matter where you are in
terms of scale, capability,
and requirements, we're going
to have the right pricing
options for you.
So we do have a perpetual
free tier, where
you get 10 gigabytes
of storage for free,
and a whole terabyte
of execution-- query
execution, query processing
for free, no strings attached.
And we have pay
as you go pricing,
which is serverless pricing,
incredibly efficient.
You don't have to
think about anything.
But as you kind of graduate,
and become bigger and bigger,
you start caring about
additional capacity.
You start caring about
price predictability.
So we have flex slots
there that we recently
launched, and then all the way
out through the largest use
cases.
If you really care
about efficiency,
you care about price
predictability,
and you're working on these
types of annual budgets,
we have flat rate
pricing for you.
So wherever you are, BigQuery is
going to have the right pricing
options for you.
And of course, you're
not just using BigQuery.
Typically our customers are
running Sparkwork, [INAUDIBLE],,
data pandas, data frames, other
types of execution engines.
And at the same time,
they keep their data
in other places other
than BigQuery storage.
So whether it's MySQL,
Postgres, CloudSQL--
it could be a
potentially Bigtable.
It could be Google Drive,
and it could be open data
lakes like Parquet and ORC.
So we provide interoperability
with all of these layers.
So BigQuery storage API and
its ecosystem of open source
connectors allow you to run
Spark, pandas, MapReduce,
and other open source
workloads directly
on top of BigQuery storage
at high levels of throughput
and parallelism.
So it's as if you're running
these workloads directly
on open storage,
directly on HDFS
without sacrificing performance.
It's a very unique and
differentiated capability
of BigQuery.
Now, if you want to
leverage BigQuery SQL,
but your data lives
outside of BigQuery,
we provide that capability.
So CloudSQL Federation
allows you to, in real time,
access data in your
relational databases
from BigQuery execution engine
using your familiar BigQuery
SQL.
And, of course, we support
Parquet and ORC Federation,
which means that you can
run BigQuery right on top
of your data lakes.
And finally, your data may be
living in these other service
providers, like Stripe, Marketo.
Maybe you have
Google internal data
sets to live within
AdWords, within YouTube,
and so on and so forth.
How do you get that data
into your data warehouse
so you can enrich it
and you can join it
against your other
relevant business data?
Well, we provide it--
we provide hundreds
of connectors that are
very easy to configure,
very easy to set up.
And we take care of the rest.
Once your connection
is set up, we simply
move that data into
BigQuery on your behalf,
and now you can do
advanced analytics on it.
SUDHIR HASBE: Perfect.
And this is just a
subset or summary
of all the different
capabilities
that we are announcing.
We know there is not enough
time in 30 minutes or 35 minutes
for us to cover everything.
There is a lot of
other sessions.
There are 30 plus sessions
that are happening, so that you
should be able to get
deep dives into all
of these different
topics, as well as
hearing more about our different
aspects of the roadmap.
I do want to highlight
one of the ESG studies.
BigQuery is providing
the lowest total cost
of ownership for our
customers across the globe.
I highly recommend
looking at the study
and then trying BigQuery out.
And finally, we are
the leaders in all
the different magic
quadrants from Gartner,
as well as Forrester [INAUDIBLE]
over the last couple of years.
This is one example.
But one of the things I want
to close today by telling you
is, when COVID-19 hit, I know
the whole globe-- everybody is
fighting the new pandemic.
A lot of organizations
came to us.
They wanted to get
access to data,
and we were able to
go ahead and make
20 plus data sets available,
globally accessible, shareable
in BigQuery.
We were able to go ahead
and make all the computation
on top of that free until I
think later part of the year.
The key thing is
BigQuery does provide us
this platform that we
can share data, share
insights with the globe, not
just within organizations.
And then that's really,
really a great, great feeling
from the team's perspective.
We want to thank you today
for joining us and hearing
what's new in BigQuery.
Thank you.